Okay.
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 20th, 2017. What's going on? How, why Ya?
I am a recording off of my laptop. If this sounds a little, ah,
um, I'm in New York City. Came in town to do the, uh,
the Patrice O'Neal benefit, the fifth annual Patrice O'Neal benefit.
Um,
it's going to be going down tomorrow night at the New York City Center.
And uh, it should be a great time. As you can tell. I'm a little jet lag.
I took a fucking red eye last night and there was this lady,
no, what's hilarious is when you have a kid, if you actually go on the road,
the big thing when you go on the road now is not, you know, not the booze,
not the cigars, not hanging out with your friends. It becomes like, Holy Shit,
I'm going to get eight hours of uninterrupted sleep. So I get on the plane
and um,
there's a woman not in my row,
but the next row over she had a little baby and it was crying.
Okay.
And then the dude next to me fell asleep and started snoring. And,
uh, I just started laughing. And, um, the, the poor woman,
like she was traveling alone with this baby. Right. And it was a baby too.
Maybe a little bit older than mine. I, I don't, I'm, this is my first kid,
so I can't judge. I don't know if this kid was two, three months,
I don't know if it was 26 years old and had that disease that that fucking baby
had in the Brad Pitt movie. Remember that?
Remember the old baby was just hanging around and um,
you know, that guy wanted to like bang the chick and he's like,
you got to get this old baby out of here cause it's weird me out. Which,
you know, I'd like to think that that guy later on,
once his dick wasn't hard and he was thinking clearly again,
he probably was thinking, you know, I probably shouldn't have said that.
You know, I probably shouldn't have trashed that old baby.
That was the name of a band. I used to play an old baby and uh, you know,
we got, we got a record contract and everything but uh, you know,
leasing a gun at appendicitis. I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about. Um,
anyway, so the baby's fucking crying and the poor woman,
like she falls asleep and the baby's like freaking out screaming and she can't
hear it because she's like, she's fucking exhausted. She's got a baby,
she's flying with it. So,
and I'm sitting there and I'm watching that thing squirming around in her hands
are like not really holding it anymore.
So now it's like this situation like is this,
is this lady going to drop that fucking baby?
So I'm staring over there.
I'm sure other people were looking at me thinking I was given or the evil line
cause a baby was crying but I wasn't, I was just,
I what the fuck I thought I was going to do, cause I still had my seatbelt on.
Yeah.
Yeah. My safety first, then a baby's see that.
That's why I'll never be a hero.
Because what a true hero does is he sees danger and without any sort of self or
an ECE and he's safe. You know what I mean? That's to me is a hero.
Like if you're, if you're in a fucking bank, right?
And these guys come in with guns and they go to rob the place and they said,
we're going to blow everybody's fucking brains out and then you act on that.
You're not really a hero to me. Okay. Because at no point in that scenario,
where are you safe? All right.
You were immediately in the situations to, no matter how you slice it,
no matter how many fucking people you say that the end of the day you were
motivated to save your own ass and everybody else getting saved along with you
is, uh, you know, that's just collateral damage.
That means positive. But if you're outside the bank, you're like, Holy Shit,
I'm out here. I mean the Bacon, Bacon, egg and cheese sandwich, you know,
getting ready to go for a run, you know, fuel myself up.
You stretch your fucking hammies. And all of a sudden you see you,
I dunno if you look at one of those fucking giant bank windows,
you see a robbery going down and then you go in there with you Larry Bird short
shorts. Right. And fucking try to stop the ride then to me, yeah.
That's like, do you want me, you know,
like there's like the hall of fame and then there's also, you know,
people who literally have like their own wing of the hall of fame. Yeah.
To me that's like,
you know,
that's when you get to your own way. But if you're already in the shit,
I didn't, can't remember what the fuck I was talking about. Beyonce. Yeah. Okay.
Not a hero. Right. So
yeah.
I finally sort of flagged down the stewardess and she goes, yes, you know,
what can I get you? And I said,
I think what I have to fuck did I say? I said, I said,
can that baby fall? And she started laughing.
Okay.
Because she thought I was being sarcastic. Like,
I was upset with the baby crying and she thought I meant like,
can that baby fall on the ground and shut the fuck up?
And she was like taken aback. But she also laughed,
which to me immediately made her really cool that she could laugh thinking that
some guy was just being sarcastic, being like an that baby,
please fall on the fucking floor of an airplane,
knock itself out so I can get some sleep. And I was like, no, no, no, no, no,
no. I, I mean, I was, I'm concerned that it's going to fall.
So she kind of went over there to make sure the baby was all right. But, um,
I dunno. I'm a changed man. My urge was to go over and hold the baby.
What's happened to me becoming a fucking softie. You know,
I actually, you know, I told you before,
I never got mad at babies crying on airplanes cause I always felt they were,
they were just expressing exactly what I was feeling.
Um,
there's no way to get on an airplane and at some point, you know,
and unless you go on some fucking great vacation,
but if you're getting on there and you know,
you're going back to see the relatives or some business trip or something like
that, you know,
and you just see some wide body coming down the fucking aisle and you're praying
to God, the person's not going to sit next to you, but you know, they got to,
you know, something's going to fucking happen.
Um,
it'd probably be really good for you,
for your life expectancy if you had access to your emotions that you could just
break down crying.
Uh,
God, I would love to ski.
Imagine you get up on a fucking plane and it was just the 300 adults in there
just crying like babies. Yeah, I'd probably be a nightmare,
but there's a, part of me would think that that was awesome. Anyways,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about. So I, um, um,
I'm telling this fucking story in the wrong way. I actually, yesterday I did a,
I presented at an a Hollywood awards show, all freckles,
the big fucking phony himself. Um,
when all Hollywood rented a Tuxedo shout out to Mr Tux on Wilshire Boulevard,
um,
wasn't going to say yeah, I had to, uh,
had to do the presenting and I just sort of wrote something
and I quickly, when I got to the writer's guilt thing,
I immediately was like, wow,
I should have not just written what I'm gonna say once.
I should have gone over this a bunch of times.
So I just was kind of going over it in my fucking head and um,
you know, I thought I was just going to be a bunch of writers,
but there was some like actors there and shit,
like Denzel was there and uh,
who's the other guy? Yeah, uh, James Woods. It was a like,
I dunno, it was like serious fucking people that,
that thing was when you go up in front of a bunch of writers,
like no matter what they've accomplished, you don't know what they look like.
So you can't get nervous.
Like someone could literally have been sitting there and they wrote the best
picture Oscar winner fucking nine years in a row, nine years.
I know what they look like, but whatever, you know,
they could accomplish shit like that.
You have no fucking idea who they like for the whole night.
They were just pulling people out of the crowd and I would be sitting there
going, I don't, I don't know who this guy is.
And then when they would say what the fuck they did, I was like, Jesus Christ.
Um,
so with every person they pulled out of the crowd, like, I don't know,
I just felt like the pressure was getting more and more and I just kept
muttering to myself, this is it. This is it one and done.
I'm never doing one of these fucking things again. This is not, this is not my,
uh, this is not my thing. I don't know what the fuck I'm doing here. This is,
these people are, are smart. They are accomplished.
Like,
like the shift that, you know, some of the fucking people in the crowd,
there's stuff that they do.
You know what it takes to write a movie and actually get it made and then get
that fucking giant rock up the fucking hill as opposed to me who just,
hey, here's a tis a shit show, but I think we'll try this. You know,
as I'm riding over on the subway to a club,
um,
I don't know. It just kept getting bigger and bigger and bigger and a patent.
Oswald hosted it. Fucking murder. This monologue was great. Uh,
his mandala was so great. I kind of forgot that I had to go up.
I was just sitting there was a fan and joying for an hour person was there and
he went out and somehow gave his credit card information.
That's what he did before he said the nominees.
And somehow we made that fucking hilarious. And once again,
it just made me feel like, why am I here? I shouldn't be here.
So I'm finally waiting to go up. And, um,
James Woods is giving some sort of, um, lifetime achievement award
to a Oliver Stone. Thank God this shit wasn't televised.
Um,
which is also fucking, somebody made a reference to that. Like,
nobody works fucking harder than those guys.
And they wouldn't even put it on TV because nobody knows what they look like,
I guess.
Um,
so he tells the whole fucking story of being best friends with Oliver Stone for
35 years and I have to go on after this shit. And I just,
yeah, that's why I just kept thinking. I just kept,
I started looking at my watch the way I used to back in the day when I would do
newness, which, uh,
is an stand up expression for basically you're doing a college gig and the show
is essentially at 12 noon or one in the afternoon.
It's usually in a cafeteria and it is a fucking nightmare.
You go up there and you have to do an hour, you have to stand in front of it.
Just stand in public in a cat fucking college cafeteria in front of like God
knows how many, three, four, five,
600 fucking college students who have no idea
that there's going to be any sort of performance, forget about a comedy show
and um, like the, the level of just fucking like, I don't even, I,
I think it's like,
it's really hard for me to be humiliated now after go doing enough of those.
Like you just get so walled off, you just, you just accepted you like, okay,
my life is going to suck. Like it's never sucked.
Um,
starting in about three minutes, however, in an hour,
in three minutes I'm going to be back in my rental car and I'm never going to
see these fucking again. That's what, that's what I,
that's the mindset I used to go into.
I used to go up there and I used to just psych myself up to be like,
how hard can I commit to these jokes?
How big of an ass can I make of myself?
And
just to try and to not give into the horror slash negative vibe of the
situation. Because if you did that, I learned the hard way.
You were going to burn through an hour of material in like 17 minutes and you
were going to be angry and, um,
your agent was going to get a call. Um, so anyways,
James Woods is going on and on and on. He brings up fuck it.
And I don't mean that in a bad way, it's just that, um,
Oliver stone has accomplished so many things and all of their stone goes up
there. And after a night of fucking Trump bashing,
just so eloquently stated that all the countries we've invaded,
all of the stuff that we've done.
And he said during all of our history of doing this,
there's been both Democrats and Republicans holding the office of President.
I thought I should have got more of an applause break, but um,
you know, I don't know.
The Trump thing is just such low hanging fruit at some points. Like we get it.
Hollywood does not like Trump. Having said that,
this fucking guy went on stage and did the best Trump.
I should've gotten his name. I was so fucking nervous for what I had to do.
He did the best Trump impression, I,
the fucking nuance performance that he did.
Uh, [inaudible]
it just, it was unbelievable. And then he did a lot of really,
really fucking harsh jokes that like, even like writers,
they sit in fucking writer's room.
You wouldn't think that you could get them to pull back.
It's just because they were in public. Um,
and he just totally fucking committed. So I got kind of inspired by that.
So long story short,
I'm sitting there waiting to go on. And, uh,
they had mentioned that Oliver Stone, I guess wrote Scarface, which I did know.
And I remember my mother took us to go see that my youngest brother was nine at
the time.
So I thought that was pretty cool.
So I just went out there and I sorta winged it,
told a story about how I used to think of pony was a small horse. And,
and I don't even, I can't remember what I said, but I think it went okay. And,
um,
I got off stage and I actually thought for half a second, like, you know what,
that was actually kind of fun.
And I realized that a lot of my adversion to award shows is just my own social
anxiety of not knowing how to behave when there's a room full of people just
saying positive shit to each other.
Like if that they'll give award shows, we're like, absolutely.
I'm not talking like roast. I don't like roasts either.
I don't know what happened to rose. Rose to me, used to be funny.
And then it just became just like this, you know, Tourette's, the gay,
I wouldn't fuck you with the, the dog, Dick Aides, Cock Shit cunt. You know,
it's just like, all right, so and so Z. I'm not saying any, we'll go, whoa,
whoa, go. But this Guy Bob, a dub a doable, I'd find them fucking mind.
Numbingly boring. Um, but whatever,
somewhere in between there somewhat, somewhere short of that.
Um,
if it was totally negative, I would have been comfortable.
So I don't want the fuck that says about me.
So I figured out what my hangup was with WWE. I will say though, um,
I still will never get past listening to fucking people talk politics in fucking
, uh, the environmental issues in all of that shit.
It's just like everybody knows we already know this shit. We already know it.
You're not going to inspire anybody. Like, you know,
I kind of gave a shit about the environment,
but then when that guy from fucking a third rock from the Sun said that shit
about Antartica I was like, wait a minute, this is an important issue.
Um,
I dunno,
maybe I'm just a negative con why am a negative con but I'll never be able to
again, I just, I just think that's just like some, like
it's like the Beyonce thing, you know what I mean?
Like I never would've thought that somebody could like
exaggerate the magnitude of creating life, but somehow she's done it.
Okay.
My wife gets so upset when I make fun. I don't, I mean,
I don't really have any feelings either. It's just fun to make fun of her.
Their fan base is just so fucking,
I dunno.
I was like,
I was driving me nuts when she was watching the grammys and stuff like that.
First of all, I don't get,
why does she get like a four hour performance and everybody else only gets like
fucking six seconds.
Okay.
You know, brutal, brutal. Mars is way around doing a bunch of costume changes.
You know,
she comes out dressed like a Batman villain and fuck does like 45 minutes set.
I didn't think it was straight to the other performance, but you know what,
I gotta be honest with you. I don't think I could name one, so wow.
Bootylicious that was a,
that's when she was with those other two girls that she kicked to the curb.
I gave you an an all girl group or if you're in a boy band,
you can't. At this point, people have to be so fucking educated that you know,
at some point there's going to be
okay.
Like one person is going to go solo,
you know,
it'd be extremely successful in the rest of you are just going to be sitting
around working at staples.
Hoping that the person who left and is now wildly successful as a solo artist,
we'll eventually have a couple of shit albums so they have to come back to you
to do a reunion tour. You know what I mean? Like,
do you think Justin Timberlake's ever going to do the instinct thing?
Maybe he has. I don't fucking know.
Um,
well I can say,
I guess what I'm saying is if I was in a boy band way back in the day and I
still had my reddish orange hair,
um,
I would save my money. I'd be like, you know what? Someone's going to break out.
I know it's not going to be making,
oh, whoa, whoa. Um, anyways,
how far into this podcast already? I gotta check.
I gotta check the fucking title.
Um,
hey, how about fucking, uh, the Boston Bruins? We,
we are undefeated with our new coats coach. I don't even know who was it?
Bruce Cassidy of butch Cassidy and the Sundance kid.
I already forgot his fucking name. I've been so God damn busy. Um,
hey.
You know what the best thing about having a baby is do you can watch so much
fucking sports in the first three months before they learn how to crawl around
and shit. Every morning
my faith, my like my daughter is like my new best friend.
I mean I was going to happen anyway. Sorry for the extra noise.
Who was setting the laptop down? My daughters. My new best friend. Okay.
Aside from the obvious that she's my blood, she's my daughter and everything,
but just like on a real level. She's my best friend.
I probably have watched like 20 games with her already every morning.
Right. The lovely Nia, you know,
she's exhausted cause she's still has to breastfeed at night.
Well I just have to wake up, you know,
and change a diaper every once in a while. Sorry for the hiccups here.
So in the mornings I try to give my wife like three hours at least.
You know what I mean? Like I got it down where if she just feeds her,
I can take her and then I can have inch and you know, I have a, I have like,
I have a little fucking bottle, you know, to feed her. I can,
I can go three hours. I can keep her calm for fucking three hours while a,
my wife sleeps and all that type of stuff.
So what I do is I just tape games and every morning we come upstairs and I just
put her on my chest and I just sit there and I watch games with her and um,
she starts to cry. You know what it is what's been working for me. You know,
those giant exercise balls that people use for core strengths.
I just get on one of those and I just,
just fucking bouncing up and down on the thing.
It gives them the feeling of weightlessness or some shit.
And if they start crying when you're doing the bouncing thing,
cause it's killing my fucking back, right.
I just go fucking crazy big air. Then they just like, you know,
it makes them almost almost like when a dog wants to kill somebody and if you
make a loud enough noise and they fucking looks in the, in another direction,
it just, they, they completely forget that they wanted to kill somebody.
Babies are like that. They start to cry.
If you get this stomach to drop the kind of go make this face like Whoa,
you know,
the eyes get big and shit and then they just kind of get into that vibe and then
you slowly, you just slowly get it back down, two, three,
four repetitions back down to the robe level that you have and they don't cry
and um,
that eventually they fall asleep than I do. You know, that I got the,
I got the fucking game on and um,
I've watched more fucking college hoop so it's going to that Duke UNC game.
I've been, you know, obviously started taping all the Duke Games. Um,
I watched Duke, Virginia, I miss them against wake forest yesterday, but uh,
I got all the rest of the year.
I think they get like they got Syracuse on Wednesday.
Then they got university of Miami and then, uh, Florida state,
and then they play UNC again, March 4th. Even if you,
you're not a huge fan of fucking college basketball.
You've got to watch that one. I Watch Kentucky, Georgia,
southern Georgia lose another heartbreaker I'll watch Wisconsin, Maryland,
which was fucking so boring.
I went into my fucking Divia and I had tape, UNC, Virginia,
and I watched that one instead. And watch that. A fucking kid.
What's his name? Number 44 one UNC. The fuck is his name.
It's a literation Justin Jamison. No,
I can't remember his fucking name. I'm, how did I fucking sleep deprived here?
Um, totally got into that.
You've been watching the NHL and because of the all star break,
you know the Celtics gave me a break, you know, cause they, they,
they were on the all star break and I got to watch a bunch of college shit.
So anyways, uh, I landed here in New York,
slept the whole fucking flight head, my ims, cut my earplugs and I was all good.
That lady didn't drop that baby and um,
everything was fine. You know, nobody tried to hijack the plane,
everything was good.
And I get in a car taking a cab ride over to the hotel and, uh,
they had Trump on the radio and it's just a fucking guy, man. Jesus Christ.
He was talking about some terrorist thing that happened in Sweden. He goes,
I mean, this happened in Sweden. People swaying, he yells,
sweetened again. He just sounded like, I just, I cannot fucking believe,
I can't believe that this guy is president and I cannot believe that he's,
he's so successful out in that he is just implementing everything.
Like I didn't know you could just go around Congress with these fucking
executive orders. Man. It's fucking hilarious that he's found yet another,
this guy is like, if there's like a hall of fame for finding the loophole,
I mean, he really is like, guy's a fucking genius.
I just wish he was more stable because, um, you know,
Hillary would have scared the shit out of me and a much quieter,
dignified way and not even dignify just as far as she knows how to ran.
I ran give a fucking speech, but, um,
I dunno, I dunno,
the day he stops reacting to people saying shit about them in award shows,
I think I'll feel a little more comfortable with the fact that he's, uh,
you know, in power,
this is like the most simple and basic thought I've ever had in my life, right.
Is they keep talking about how the tensions, you know,
Ben of Russia was actually in communication with Trump in Europe.
So nervous because, uh, Russia's fucking doing whatever over there and blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
And these guys are thinking this and these guys are thinking that.
And I just was thinking like, Hey, what, what is it?
Everybody just fucking relax.
Okay.
Yeah. And I don't mean you, I don't mean me, we just regular,
everybody's just walking around, you know, living your life,
getting a fucking newspaper. Why don't these cons up top?
Why don't you just fucking relax?
I know this is way too overly simplified, but like,
I would have no fucking idea what another country was thinking or planning to do
if you weren't yammering about it. All right?
If the other people on the other side weren't Yammer and about what the fuck
we're trying to do. You know, why don't we just stay?
Everybody just stays home. Where's your country?
You fucking stay there, right? I don't mean refugees.
I just mean leaders in your arms. Just fucking stay there.
We bring our guys back. Everybody just sorts out their own shit,
you know?
And when people come to your country to go to your fucking waterpark or
whatever, you'd given them Mickey Mouse ears. You get them.
You can be put on a show. What? Why can't it just fucking be like that?
You know why? Cause they want to get the fucking, you know,
it's natural resources and money. That's all the fuck it is. It's all it is.
I don't give a fuck about any of that goddamn rhetoric.
That's why the fuck they doing it.
And all they do is sit there scaring the shit.
I just wish everybody could like regular people just collectively all at the
same time be like and fuck it. Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
Fuck it. Fuck everything you're saying. Fuck wars. Fuck all of this shit.
If you fucking rich concept have a problem with each other,
why don't you sit down at your yacht clubs and try and fucking work it out?
You know, play a game of seven, seven fucking something stud,
whatever the final on car play,
whatever the fuck is he do you know enough with the blowing up of people in Shit
? Yeah. Adam,
I know it's completely oversimplified but Nike at sometime.
But when I think about having mind control, like that's what I think of doing.
I yeah, you know,
we'd like people on the terrorist groups all the way to our country start saying
we're going to go to war. It's just like, yeah, no, you know,
no we're not. Alrighty then and then just see what the fuck they would do.
I think they would literally lose their fucking minds.
They wouldn't know what to do cause they'd just be like, well now what?
What am I going to do if I'm not out there trying to get more?
What am I going to do? Sit here alone with my own thoughts.
How many do you think would actually take their own lives? Like,
take that fatty over there in North Korea. I'm really in over my head.
By the way,
if you haven't realized that this is like meet the press with no press or
information, it's the same thing. I'll probably get sued by that program for,
uh, ruining their format. Um,
that fat cut there. You know,
all softy there doesn't have a whisker on his fucking face. Like,
you know what I mean?
Like you want to be able to grow a fucking crazy beard man. You know that,
that's one thing I'll have to commend that. I don't even know his name.
Kim Jong Il, is that his name? Was it
Kim Jong Il Jr Sonny boy. Um,
Frank Sinatra jr whatever the fuck his name is over there.
Like the fact that he can't grow a beard and he still has people scared
shitless. You know, like what if they could just collectively over there,
everybody just be like, yeah, dude, we don't give a fuck anymore. Right.
And everybody just goes about their business.
He still gets to live in that big fucking house, but nobody listens to.
Okay.
Like how, like nobody will kill for him anymore. No army will do anything,
but he still gets to keep the giant fucking house.
Like how fucking freaked out would he be?
No,
nobody really goes over and talks to him or anything.
So eventually he has to come out and go to like a farmer's market, you know?
And then you don't talk to him.
You force him to acclimate himself socially. You know,
like anybody else would if they, when the new guy in town,
if I had mind control, that's what the fuck I would do. Um,
what I, I don't know what do I, I would probably do some evil,
shitty [inaudible] if you could control the entire world's fucking brains. Yeah.
I don't think I, I don't think I can handle that. All right. Fuck that. I,
that was a dumb idea. All right, let's, let's read some, um,
let's read some fucking, uh, advertising here for this week. All right.
Uh, wince pronounced a wink, spelled wind.
So without the e w. I. N. C. Yeah. All right. We'll see. India,
November. Charlie, finding new. Great. New Wine is tough. You know,
I can tell you I've got to agree with these.
I got agree with these fucking people. I'm a said consequent.
I know they don't like what I say that during these reads,
I actually agree with these guys. Finding good wine is difficult.
It's like trying to find a good cigar, like where the fuck do you start?
There's so many of them. There's so many articles. There's so much fake news.
Fake news about the cigars. I'm finding new wine is tough.
That's why I've been telling you all about our sponsor club,W club,
JB Atlanta, not praising anymore.
I'd fly fish and paint and how they make it so easy to get wine personalized to
your palate and delivered right to your door.
And here's a little update free for you.
Club w is now called wince, spelled called wink,
spelled w. I. N. C. A new name and an improved look.
But here's the important part.
It's still the same amazing wine company introducing you to new wines that you
love.
Why did they switch from club w to something that you'd really difficult to
pronounce and spell winked works directly. It's not,
I'm not saying it's difficult to pronounce,
but like if you looked at w I n C I mean you're not thinking wink.
What does that stand for?
We incorporate no [inaudible] wins.
Works directly with wine makers and growers from all over the world to create
delicious wines and deliver it right to your door.
Weeks' 100% satisfaction guarantee means if you don't like the bottle of a
bottle they send you, they'll replace it with a bottle you love.
No questions asked. Jesus Christ, Ernest Hemingway,
born a hundred years too soon. You don't get sent random bottles.
Wake is a personalized wine membership that recommends wine specifically for you
based on the results of your palate profile quiz.
I can't believe I'm such a drunk and I haven't,
you haven't fucking used this yet.
The great thing about drinking wine is you don't feel like a drunk. You know,
you actually feel like you read a book or something.
You can also rate all of the wine you receive from wink,
so they'll learn about you with every order and constantly personalize the wine
they send.
Sign up for Winc right now and gain immediate insider access to the best fine
wine from all over the world.
Find out for yourself why yours truly and thousands of other satisfied wine
lovers are raving about Winc. Well, I'm doing it because you're paying me.
The best part. Winc is offering my listeners $20 off right now.
When you go to try winc.com they'll even cover the shipping,
shipping, shipping.
Think about that and you'll get fine wine personalized to your palate,
delivered right to your door.
Try Winc and get $20 off and complimentary shipping right now.
When you go to try and wake.com as try w I n c.com/.
Bar Why don't they have that with like whiskeys and scotches? You know why?
Cause that's, that's mean, that's mean alcohol, you know what I mean?
Okay.
I mean, you ship a bunch of wine and what's going to happen,
you know some woman's going to slur around,
some guy will start crying. It's just wine, right?
I hope this isn't making too much noise as I'm moving this thing around,
but like I can only sit in one position for so long. It's part of it.
We're getting
old. Alright. Oh look.
Who was able to to to [inaudible] me on these or the rug Kaiso wine to do too.
To
me on these. Me On these,
you pissed your pants but you have fine because they have that fucking modal.
It'll dry up the grapes and you'll be a power when you take,
you're not saying your dick out, Yo,
I hope you drank some fucking white wine or your balls will be purple.
Me undies,
picture of will picture a world we're putting on a new pair of underwear isn't
just fresh is stepping into a better day. So you got to take a shower first.
You can't just put it on a fresh pair on underwear. You gotta take a shower.
Then you put it on a fresh pair of underwear that you combine that with a fresh
pair of socks telling you right now your energy is going to be crazy. Like,
do you realize that there's this women out there that married guys because the
first time they met them,
they were wearing a fresh pair of underwear and socks and they just felt this
amazing energy from them, you know?
And then now they're stuck in this lovely loveless marriage wondering where it
all went. And what they have to understand is that like, you know, ladies,
if you, if you want your guide to treat you nice, okay?
Every once in a while you got to go out and you got to make sure you update his
fucking underwear and sock drawer. You put them in a better mood.
You know what I mean? You don't have to cower in the corner anymore.
All right? Think about it. Underwear.
It's the first thing you put on in the last thing you take off. Unless you,
Matthew mcconaughey,
why would you settle for anything less than the best feeling underwear on the
planet? Um,
Yonnie's focuses solely on producing the most comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced. This is all they fucking do. 24, seven.
My friends at me undies, I don't know.
You cons sent me a few pairs awhile back and now I can't imagine wearing
anything else I wear. I wear you only gave me fucking two.
Okay. And I am a man over the age of 45,
which means I can't figure out the fucking Internet.
So even if I wanted to order some underwear, which I desperately need to do,
most of my underwear is at least from two presidents ago. Um,
I'm everything in this ad.
I'm the exact person that should be getting me on these. Um,
evidently it really makes each day that much better for the price of two
cocktails.
UNDIES will deliver your new favorite pair of underwear right to your doorstep.
Better Day guarantee you try them on. If they're not the most comfortable,
best feeling uneasy I've ever had,
they'll refund you and let you keep your first pair for free.
Included in the price is this sweet touch of modal.
Why don't they say sweet touch in your crotch area?
A special fabric made with the best in class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be three times softer than cotton.
These Uber Cozy undies are sold exclusively on my undies website.
Will you enjoy free standard shipping in the U s plus Canada? Uh,
and for a limited time, everyone in my audience gets 20% off their first order,
but if you have, but you have to go to our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash bar with the me undies.
Better Day guarantee you have nothing to lose. So don't wait any longer.
Go to me undies.com/for right now for 20% your first order. That's
mandy.com/bar. All right.
Okay.
Oh fuck. He likes everybody Hallux. Your unique.
Oh God. You don't walk like everyone else talk like everyone else.
Just sleep like everyone else. So why is your mattress one size fits all well?
Because there's a basic shape of a fucking human being.
Not to mention his size because, oh, I'm sorry.
I say the wrong answer because it truly customized mattress will cost you five
to 10,000 bucks until now.
Go to Helen's sleep.com and answer a few simple questions and they'll want a
three d biomechanical model of your body. Yeah.
And then you'll show up in the next season of fucking Westworld through the
proprietary algorithms they developed with the help of the world's leading
ergonomics and biomechanics experts. The result,
the most comfortable mattress you've ever slept on.
Yeah, I'd have it. A robot made in your fucking image. Uh,
Helux customers report at 30% improvement in overall sleep quality.
And for couples that customize each side of the mattress,
your mattress arrives at your door in about a week. How to fucking,
they do this in a week and shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes,
they're all talking about heloc sleep. You have a hundred nights to try it out.
And if you don't love it, they'll pick it up for free,
grows and give you a hundred a hundred percent refund, no questions asked.
Go to Heloc, sleep.com/bar and get $50 off your order. That's helix,
sleep.com/bar Helen's sleep.com/bar
um,
all right. Lastly,
but not leastly stamps.com avoid the hassle of the post office and mailing
everything from postcards to envelopes to packages, domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes online with no equipment to lease,
no longterm commitments. Click print mail and you're done.
Unlike the post office stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your convenience.
24 seven seven days a week.
stamps.com brings all this services of the US Postal Service right to your
fingertips by imprint official us postage for any letter, any package,
any class of mail,
using your own computer and printer stamps.com will even help you decide the
best class of mail based on your needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter.
I use stamps.com anytime I'm sending out my fucking posters. You know,
whoring myself out right now.
You can enjoy the stamps service with a special offer that includes a full week
trial plus postage and a digital scale with longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com. Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirthsatstamps.com enter bar. All right.
There we go. Jesus Christ. I'm done with that shit.
Sorry for sitting on the fucking laptop. How much time will be up to here?
Um,
oh, 38 minutes. Perfect. It's time to start reading some letters. Before I do,
I want to thank everybody, uh,
the night before the Patrice O'Neal benefit for everybody that is, uh,
bought tickets once again. Um,
and we've been able to keep this benefit going and I cannot even begin to tell
you how much this has helped his loved ones. Um,
it's just been such a great thing and uh,
his sad and tragic is it always will be that he passed away too soon.
Um, just all you guys stepping it up every year and seeing like,
just how much that has changed, uh,
and help the people that he was helping out when he was alive. It's just,
I can't thank you enough. All right. Okay. Uh,
Friday the 13th. Bullshit. Oh, this is, um,
this is in regards to what I was talking about that like why is Friday the 13th
unlucky rather than Monday the 13th so this person comes to me with this.
It says built with regards to your podcast involving Friday the 13th.
The main superstition that's spread was amongst sailors during the late 17th
century who considered setting sail on any Friday to be a bad omen.
And given that most people, including pirates, were god-fearing Christians.
The 13 the 13 relating to the last supper being the night before Jesus died,
according to historical hearsay,
the 13 relating to the last supper,
the night before Jesus died,
were there 13 apob there was 12 apostles plus Jesus. That was 13
if the 13th fell on fry. Well first of all,
I don't understand why didn't sailors wait until the 17 hundreds
yeah,
they waited 1700 years, minus 32 years.
So they waited 1,600 and fucking 68 years.
People have been sailing for fucking ever.
They were sailing back in Jesus's Day, right? Well,
I guess there was no fucking social media.
So it took a while for the story to get out. I Dunno. Anyways,
if the 13th fell on Friday,
most dogs imports would be emptied out as sailors believe this to be the
greatest ill home and there could possibly be and for reason and reason enough
not to work on the day or get out of bed for that matter.
As most people of that time hung crucifixes over their bed and believed it to be
the safest place in the house. Now I'm going to say most people didn't do that.
You know what I mean? I would just say like if back in the day,
if TV news existed,
those were the people's houses that they would go to and they would try to scare
the shit out of everybody about Friday the fucking 13th but I think that,
I think that there was a lot of fucking people back then, even back then.
Then we're just like, dude, are you fucking you a fucking,
it was people back then that said, Jesus Shit never happened.
They would say [inaudible] it's a couple of pieces of wood.
It makes the shape of a cross. It's, it's,
it's not like some holy fucking thing. I have to,
I'm imagine it was plenty of people.
Granted they probably got lit on fire if they said some shit like that.
I have no idea. So anyways, it sounds pretty
okay.
Uh, basic now. But back in the day, people simply didn't know any better.
If you fell sick around a Friday, you were unlucky around, uh,
around a 13th of a month. Also unlucky.
But the two together somehow was much worse. Dipshit ancestors,
um, oh, they just lack the information. Jesus Christ. What about us?
We're the smart ones ruining the fucking oceans. The Great Barrier Reef is dead.
You don't, they didn't fucking go.
They would've killed it if they had the fucking opportunity. You know what?
They're the same dip shits we are right now. All right. Canadian, uh,
bus B header. Oh, you know what I, I meant to look this up.
So did you hear about this guy who beheaded and eight another guy and they set
free?
How the fuck is he allowed free and why wasn't he executed?
How do they know he won't relapse into another murder slash dinner?
Am I crazy by saying, if you murder someone, you should be murdered yourself.
Um, well, yeah, if, if people didn't lie, you know,
if they weren't people wrongly convicted, I mean, I just, I feel like though,
if it's beyond a shadow of a fucking doubt,
uh,
you know, if you do some of the animals kids,
or if you eat somebody's head on a bus, I w I would have to say, you know, yeah,
he want to fucking, you want to handle it? Uh, oh, you don't,
I forgot the fucking, before I get into this shit,
I forgot to hide my youtube page. I'm finally going to start posting videos.
I'm gonna Start doing tours of cities again,
and you can watch all of this on my youtube page.
www.youtube.com/user/monday morning podcast,
youtube.com/users/monday morning podcast.
All right, let me, let me try to find the link of this fucking guy,
Jesus Christ, fucking eat and send me how you, you mean,
how would you even go about eating ahead?
Um,
oh, this is a different one. Wait a second. Is that no link to this one?
What just happened here? Oh,
I do have a link. Okay.
I'm sorry guys. This is usually what I'll try to hit. Fucking pause.
You don't have to go through the torture of this. All right, Garrett is,
there it is. Okay. Here we go.
Canadian man who be headed bus passenger.
Granted total freedom. Winnipeg,
Manitoba, Aka winter pig.
Homer the jets.
I'm a Canadian man who was found not criminally responsible for beheading and
cannibalizing a fellow passenger on a Greyhound bus.
Has been granted his freedom.
He cut somebody's head off, fucking ate it and wasn't criminally responsible.
Well, who was
Manitoba's Criminal Code Review Board announced Friday. It will give.
It has given. Will Baker formally known as Vince Lee. Well,
thanks for fucking up his identity. Um, and a,
an absolute discharge. Meaning he is no longer subject to monitoring
man who thought roommate was a Zombie. Pleads guilty to murder. Okay.
What the fuck is going on in Canada? That's a completely different story.
Here's a rabbit hole. I'll read that one. Next. Baker a diagnosed schizophrenia,
killed him. McLean, a young carnival worker.
Jesus Christ. See, this is why you never take buses, Carney workers,
schizophrenia x. It's just, you know,
you've taken your life in your hands.
A young carnival worker who was a complete stranger to Baker in 2008 a year
later, he was found not criminally responsible due to mental illness. Okay?
McClain's mother, Carol,
whatever has been outspoken against granting bakers for her eyes own mother is
saying,
don't set this guy free saying there'll be no way to ensure he continued to take
his meds. She declined.
Comment in a F in a post on Facebook Friday saying, I have no words.
Baker was initially kept in a secure wing of a psychiatric.
Costco was given more freedom every year.
He's been living on his own and Winnipeg apartment since November,
but we're still subject to monitoring, turning to insured.
He took his medication, bakers, docker, dude,
this is fucking insane. You let a head eat or go free.
Um, I dunno, Dude.
Do you think that they should kill people who are mentally insane? I mean,
what are you going to do? You're going to stick them in a room and beat them.
For instance, Flintstone vitamins for a still life, right?
Madam thought roommate was a Zombie pleads guilty of murder.
These are all just mentally ill people here, man.
A 38 year old man who said he beat his roommate to death because he thought she
was a Zombie, pleaded no contest. The secondary murder.
Now I'm sitting there wondering,
maybe he just beat her to death and now he's just trying to act like he's
fucking insane. Um, the guy entered the plea Friday,
the strangling and beating death of 35 year old Jennifer Lopez.
Not the same. I want to obviously, uh,
the Kansas City Star reported Wallace told police he had fallen asleep after
taking a methamphetamine court.
Documents said he began beating Lopez when she woke up because he thought she
was a Zombie. He told police he kept being Lopez until something made him stop.
Wow. This is not a funny podcast anymore. Now is it? Um,
yes.
Uh, should you be murdered if you murder somebody? Uh,
I think without a fucking doubt, if they know you did it.
Um,
and uh, yeah. Yeah.
I don't know. I mean I saw, you know,
I saw it so I don't want to say what this fucking person didn't do a kid,
but the kid died and like I was just like,
why is that person still walking on the earth?
There's definitely times where I feel that and I don't think that that makes us
as bad as they are.
Um,
but prison is a big business, so you know, they want that fucking guy in a cell.
All right. Ministry of truth. Hey there Billy. Hey there.
Bill you of rights. I'm sorry guys. I'm so fucking jet lag too.
This podcast is really just fucking lagging here. Dragging I should say.
Lots of people are comparing Trump to Hitler. Uh, but back in December,
Obama tried to quietly pass a bill that would allow the government. Yeah,
I saw this have jurisdiction over news and outgoing information on all channels.
I. E. TV, Internet, radio. That includes you.
You can read the fine print in the article below.
Also fuck all the people listening who haven't read the legislation but are
already up in arms because it goes against who they cheer for. Amen to that.
Amen to that. Everybody, like, like last night,
all these fucking guys at this fucking awards show,
everybody trashing and Donald Trump,
nobody brings up the fact that Obama basically signed something that is going to
implement and in front of the level of fucking censorship like there,
they're basically going to decide what is real news and what is fake news.
I mean, I'd like to think, because I openly admit that I don't read
and the shit that I say is just fucking absurd that I would be,
you know, exempt. But who knows.
But like people with blue ties do this shit all the fucking time. And that's,
that's what kills me about people who wear red ties and watch Fox News and the
Hollywood people. Like they just cannot see the bullshit all out there.
The only six, it's like,
it's like listen to what a fanatic red sox and Yankee Fan,
you know what I mean? You know,
give each other's shit for buying titles and fucking abusing steroids.
And it's like, no, we, we both did it. We both did it.
We should hang our heads in shame collectively. Um,
all right. Let me see if I can find this. This are, I,
I don't really even want to fucking read this because this is just so fucking,
uh, let's see.
Yeah.
Today I sign into law S. Dot. Two nine four three,
the National Defense Authorization Act for the fiscal year 2017 this act
authorizes fiscal year 2070 appropriations principally for the Department of
Defense and the Department of energy national security programs provides vital
benefits for military personnel families. Okay. Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. And where do we get to the,
okay,
yeah. Dude, I can't read all of this.
I can't read all of this on a fucking,
this will take me fucking three hours to read out to this. What's,
this would have to be a part of a, a mini series for me to read all of this.
Okay. A, the, here's some bull in bold.
The first priority is developing a whole of government strategy for countering
the foreign propaganda in disinformation being wage waged against us and our
allies by our enemies. Now that reads great, but it's basically,
you know, they want, yeah. Listened to our propaganda,
not their fucking propaganda. You know,
our version of what's going on is right and their version is wrong.
We're all fallible. We're all fucking human beings, but we don't make mistakes.
They do. So, I dunno, it just gets back to all of that shit. And you know what,
sir? You're never going to solve.
And even everybody's sin starts fucking screaming at each other.
And if you ever bring up something like that,
people call you a socialist and tell you to get the fuck out of the country.
If you,
if you would ever even remotely suggest that this government would ever fucking
lie, they all lie to their fucking people. Uh Oh God, they'll shut up. Okay,
dear Billy beer thighs. Um,
forgive my poor English. Well,
the fact that you come on Billy beer thighs in a fucking second language is
pretty amazing. So I, yeah, I think you're in, which she's fucking great. Um,
I am a native Berliner but I have family across Germany.
One of my female cousins was harassed on the way to work by some people who are
different.
I didn't want to s I do not want to say just a different race or religion,
but also a different way of thinking.
They are not native to Germany and are not acclimating well to western life.
I am not a racist and I find the issues very sensitive,
but I believe that reality has to play a part in one subjective view.
I'm not against refugees or anyone displaced because of terrible political and
military situations. But I also have a new opinion because of my cousin.
She is okay,
but it had 19 stitches in the back of her neck and head from a bottle thrown at
her because she was a woman walking alone at night.
This is not the first time this has happened in our town.
Um,
that was good enough to show good graces to refugees. Uh,
if countries are going to let people in,
they have to at least be okay with women having certain rights.
Should they not forget about religion or relace that's just good and bad.
Um,
I think am I a bad person from becoming a more cautious person when it comes to
refugees? Thank you. And cheers on your new child. Uh, no, not at all.
I mean, a lot of that and also people's prejudice because you're German,
they're gonna fucking think a certain way. But like, you know,
if one of the elements that comes into play is that from wherever these other
people are from,
that a woman walking alone at night is suggesting that she's fucking, I dunno,
I dunno what loose or having sex or whatever the fuck it is that's gonna make
them throw a goddamn bottle. Like how do you not address that?
Um, and also to me,
it's like what kind of a fucking person, you know,
when I go to another country, like whatever I see, I just go, oh,
I guess that's how they do it over here. I don't think like, you know, well,
I'm from someplace else. And this is the way we do it.
So I'm gonna act like we're still in my country. I think that's ignorant, but,
um, never underestimate the power of religion. You know,
when people really get into it when they really fucking get into it.
Um,
okay.
I don't, you know, there's,
there's something where your brain goes on like autopilot and you just let
religion make decisions for you.
And rational thought kind of goes out the fucking window and you just start
breaking one commandment after another. Uh,
like you tell me one religion out there,
if you could find it in whatever book it is that you read that say it's,
that says it's fucking okay to throw a fucking bottle at a woman
walking alone at night. I mean, it shouldn't you, I mean, if you think it's,
you should've walked her home if you were concerned about like, I don't know.
I don't understand. Like, um, but yeah, one of the things,
um, I think refugees should, like, if I fuck I say this,
this country goes to complete shit and there's a big war and all of a sudden
they're hunting down fucking bald red heads and I need to seek political asylum
or some shit in another country. When I go there,
the first thing I'm going to do is try to learn the fucking language and then
I'm going to try to figure out, okay,
how do they do shit over here? You know what I mean?
So I don't fucking offend anybody. And so I don't get the shit kicked out of me.
But I would say the type of people that throw a bottle like that,
um, you know,
they're also the kind of people that if they were in a higher up in a corporate
thing that they would be a
pilfering the coffers as they say or whatever.
Like there's just certain people out there that just, they're not good people.
There's certain people that are just not smart people. Um,
that's one of the fucking problems with human beings is just a lot of mouth
breathing morons. And, uh, when you accept a bunch of refugees,
you know,
you're going to get some fucking super smart people all the way down to mouth
breathing morons. Um, I don't think you're,
you know,
why wouldn't you be more cautious when it came to refugees if something like
that happen? I mean, now having said that, within your own country,
you also have neo Nazis.
Okay.
You know what I mean? So, you know,
a few suggesting getting rid of all refugees,
then you should also do something about Neo Nazi. So, um,
the hard fucking thing when people go to a new country is they don't look like
the people that are there.
So they stick out like a fucking sore thumb and people stop looking at them as
human beings. They just look at them as just one giant group.
Whereas if you look at a fucking neo Nazi, he's still a fucking white dude.
I'm assuming you're white German, right? And you're like, yeah, that guy,
he's a fucking moron. You know what I mean?
You just looking at him like he joined a stupid club,
despite the fact that those people can do some really horrific shit too. So, um,
but I don't think,
okay,
you know, you're a bad person for becoming more cautious. Um,
but I would also remain open minded that there's going to be some really great
people that were lucky enough to get out of those bad situations.
And that's the hard part. The easy thing is to just say,
fuck all of these people. And uh, you know, that's, that's the basic,
let's sit down and eat some fritos and cake. Um, or you can actually
do the crunches
in your cardio and actually try to look at people as individuals.
Now having said that, when the sun goes down at night, all bets are off.
You have to look at people, you know, the most cautiously, eh,
as cautiously as you possibly can,
because I guarantee you that even if they had a fucking rule about that during
the day, if there was a bunch of people walking around,
but the chances of them doing that during the day would have been much less. So,
um,
I'm sorry that happened to 'em you one of your cousins.
Uh, I hope it doesn't turn you into a hateful person.
You seem like you're trying to be measured. I Dunno,
but it would suck if you became another hateful person because uh,
it's just going to add fueled all of this shit. Blue Tie, red tie. Shit.
All right, dear Billy Butkus on Valentine's Day,
my ex who I love, people who know how to use whom,
you know, who and whom. I'd looked up to definition fucking a hundred times.
I believe I've read it on this podcast.
I still for the life of me cannot figure it out. I'm on Valentine's Day.
My ex who I had been dating for three years,
came to my job at a bar with a new much younger date,
sat with her for hours and proceeded to get a cab home with her.
My coworkers obviously told me and I was devastated.
Well that's why he did it.
We've been broken up for two and a half months and it was a really tough
breakup. I know I deserve better,
but I feel like he's driving me out of a small town that I generally love.
This isn't the first time he's a public show with a woman with women.
Um,
at this point I just want them want to move and start over what it should take.
Uh, my take is that you, uh,
you're a lucky woman that you, you,
you didn't hit your wagon to someone that's dead fucking petty. Um,
then yeah, I don't, I, yeah, I like that. Like that's,
yeah.
I just liked the way you described it.
I look at that guy as though he's pathetic and I feel like,
and I feel bad for the woman that he brought there because I feel like he was
barely listening to her in pretending to be smiling,
having a good time as he was trying to look around to see if he could catch you.
I mean, he basically went out of his way to hurt you when obviously when you're,
you, you're going to break up with somebody.
There's going to be that awful pain.
Cause usually somebody wants it and the other person doesn't.
So it's bad enough that that went down. Now if you dumped him.
But I feel like if you dumped him, you wouldn't be that upset about it. Um,
and you did say it was really tough. So, uh,
what I would say is have you do yourself a Salvatore glass of fucking wine,
whatever your poison is that, um,
you didn't marry this count. And, uh,
I dunno, I think at some point, I mean if you really love, be ashamed, if,
if,
if you really loved living where you were at that you would move just because
some shallow con is bringing some woman. I mean,
he obviously does not give a fuck about that one. Cause I have to tell you this,
if that guy in two and a half months found the one and found true love,
Liz, petty shit with you would not even be an issue. So
maybe a new way of looking at it is feeling bad for the woman that he's with.
Um, because he's wasting her time. And I mean,
I can guaran fucking tee you.
She has no idea who you are. And if she does,
then the two fucking psychos that deserve each other,
that should both be sterilized because they're going to make an evil baby.
So there you go. That's what you walked away from. Um,
but as far as like, you know,
at this point you want to move and start over and all depends on what you got
going on in your town. That's a pretty a big move. Uh,
you know, let a few days go by, see if you feel that again and just,
I don't know,
just really focused on the type of person that would do something like that to,
to really just go out of your way to hurt somebody and know,
say I've heard a bunch of people in my life but to like go out of your fucking
way. Like that's like the deaths.
Like the difference between first degree in second degree continuous, there
was, you know, second degree. It's just spontaneously happens. You know,
you guys got all this history and you just said something fucking horrible or
starts chatting up some shit there at the bar,
but to fucking sit there and like methodically plan it out like that,
that guy's a fucking psycho and congratulations to you,
the east on your fucking life anymore. Um,
yeah. And don't fuck with this food. That's a petty thing too. That's bad con.
Fuck all that. All right, that's the podcast for this week.
Thank you to everybody for listening. And um,
thank you for the writers guild for letting me be a presenter.
I actually really had a good time once, once I got, once I got out there,
I had a good time. But other than that, I was like freaking out. Like,
what the fuck am I doing here? And also please check out my youtube page.
Like I said,
I'm really going to start posting videos and all that shit up there. Uh,
maybe it'll take a couple of,
I'll do a video of something at the Patrice O'Neil, um, comedy benefit, um,
some backstage shit or something like that. Um, and once again,
we youtube pages, youtube.com/user/monday morning podcast. And as always,
if you'd like to donate to this podcast anytime you get to buy some shit,
you don't need it on Amazon. Uh, just go to my website,
[inaudible] dot com click on the podcast page, you'll see the Amazon link.
You Click on that, it takes you there. I get credit for driving traffic there.
Whatever you buy doesn't cost you any extra money, amount of money.
And they kicked me a little bit of cash for allegedly driving traffic,
but are going to fucking go there anyways. If you want to do it, cool. If not,
I get it. All right, go fuck yourselves and I'll check it on you on,
uh, on Thursday
husband. And he's like sitting there sipping tea with the wife and Oh,
look who came.